التوتر الامني الى جانب السياسي خيم على
مضيق تايوان في ظل المناورات التي تنفذها
الصين لليوم الثاني على التوالي ما ينذر
بامكانيه حدوث المواجهه في اي وقت
فالصين ماضيه في مناورات عسكريه حول جزيره
تايوان ردا على زياره رئيسه تايوان
للولايات المتحده ولقائها مسؤولين
امريكيين
فاين بالتحديد تلك التدريبات الصينيه وما
حجمها بحسب مصدر امني تايواني فان
التدريبات الصينيه تقع حول قناه باشي التي
تفصل تايوان عن الفلبين وتضمنت التدريبات
الصينيه محاكاه لضربات دقيقه على اهداف
رئيسيه في تايوان ولتطويق الجزيره بالكامل
كما نلاحظ هنا محاكاه ثلاثيه الابعاد
نشرتها القناه الصينيه الرسميه
وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه تقول انها رصدت
مقاتلات صينيه من بينها مقاتلات سو 30
وقذفات اتش سته فيما باتت المواجهه وشيكا
حيث توجد عشر سفن صينيه ومثلها تايوانيه
على خط المواجهه بالقرب من الخط الاوسط
للجزيره
[موسيقى]
طيب في اكدت انها لن تسهم في التصعيد
لكنها توعدت بالرد بالشكل الملائم على
تدريبات بكين
في حين قالت واشنطن حليفه تايوان انها
تراقب المناورات الصينيه عن كثب مؤكده
انها تمتلك ما يكفي من موارد وقدرات لضمان
السلام والاستقرار بالمنطقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات